even though when you got a sour face you
gonna finally groove in one of my cuz I
got the feeling I got the soul in my
muse it took us a long time to get we
didn't come here overnight we had to go
through levels of agony so I want to
educate and give at the same time what's
up believe nation it's Evan my one word
is believe and I believe in you I
believe in your potential and I want to
see that thing that you've got inside
you explode out into the world to have a
big impact for you your family and the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn from producer
DJ and singer songwriter Timbaland and
my take on his top ten rules for success
rule number eight is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best and as always
guys as you're watching if you hear
something that really really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick for yourself as well
enjoy
did you ever doubt yourself Timbo I
doubt myself all the time
Wow like I go through it now like I'd be
like man got it because not do I still
have the talent
do I still have the brain cells to
figure out what's going on today you
know check it sometimes you can get
burnt out and I want to stay always
rejuvenated to know that I can like him
nobody can have a one-up on me I want
nobody having one iron I'm always in the
competition I'm more about the music
than the money you know I'm saying I
like just like what you got no you know
somebody you don't know about this iperf
you yeah I know about it you came from
me I am the music god I feel like uh I
feel like where I'm at in life right now
just positive energy my whole spirit I
feel like I'm at my prime right now I
feel like we haven't even that's why I
put the book out I feel like I'm now I
feel like the world now I'm gonna see my
best work but it to them they might be
like I'm the nineties was better but to
me with all the technology that's being
available in ways you can do things I'm
a big kid so it's if I don't get in now
it's like I'm getting in cuz I know what
I will always want it to do when
people's like oh that's what Oh miss you
might say that's why but you know like
not not wacked like it might be to head
of his time you know I'm saying so now
time has caught up to what my thinking
was so I'm just gonna experiment and do
what I think is dope you know we didn't
have Instagram back then but one person
me like if I had like three people's
like oh man he got that that beat that
boot that DoubleTap I'm like okay all I
need to hear is too bad like me do the
same beat okay watch this then I can't
what get can you get freaky you're not
getting with a good top position in
everybody want to flip their pages and
want to do different things then I came
with a with the baseline try again less
people man that's like I've always I'm
always trying stuff cuz once I got the
stage I got your attention
mm-hmm I'm gonna do what I want to do
i'ma show you how I was gonna do it even
though when you got a sour face you
gonna finally groove in one of my
because I got the feeling I got the soul
in my musics a difference like I don't
just do it for it's got swag and he got
feelin so it's like it's a difference to
keep you guys so we can lose the swag
but if you ain't got that feeling in it
it's over
Ian James fell out I miss his 40th he
misses he did he didn't miss my knee
dissing me again but I miss his and it
was over petty stuff it was more
personal stuff and disagreements and it
was not no industry-related it was more
personal and I was wrong you know I'm
saying I was wrong I came East when I
worked on Justin he's there yo sent me a
text
We Need to Talk you know we need to hook
back up I flew down to the Brooklyn we
had them shows and we looked at each
other we just gave each other like what
you've been doing man I said man I'm I'm
right back I got my mind racing were you
real friends you will you will disagree
and not speak and come back together and
realize that we better together than the
park we had some energy and one about
doing that album man the energy in
jungle studio was so powerful the whole
point is the old Tim would have been
like you can't let nobody on the level
you gotta be just me I'm gonna fit but
the new Tim hey whatever's gonna better
the project let's go I'm rocking with
all these people you know I'm saying I
don't had on animosity with this person
I don't have no animosity with that
person I don't have no you know say I'm
just not that dude so I'm dead man like
I just embrace everybody how much do you
hear and especially just throughout the
years huh how much do you hear you can I
rap for you cannot sing for you like I
hear it all the time does it get tiring
and so now I just be like why don't you
I mean I break it down so I'm like look
what makes you different from that
person standing beside you you take that
he can sing it was like you know what
tempo you write so I give it vice as
they come to me so I'm like
put it on records because that's how the
world's gonna hear the words not gonna
hear you acapella right so you add a
they think it's you though that you
don't sound like you but you're the
connection that gets them to where
they're going these levels right right
right right well you know that right
right and I just tell people that I
don't got to tell you what the levels
are there's levels right you know what
it is it took us a long time to get we
didn't come here overnight we had to go
through levels of agony know what hit me
boy we had to go then people don't
realize that it's being cut the line out
is that we're not exactly what you have
two days at today's market price I know
and it's crazy I'm like no you have to
crawl before you walk
my feeling is whenever inspirational
find you you have to find it and luckily
for me I've been in this business a
minute I know a couple people some of
them are just permanently inspired
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you paid to pick this is on the flat
man I'm allies it's all about that he's
afraid us you know something that person
you can do about 30 reps as he had no
forgetting there one of them it's
ingenious
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
every rapid out the pose would be
so-called ha
will be terminated Nikki put up with
everything they try to tear it down
myself Michelle she's she's she's the
best she's the best not because of music
but because of who she is as a woman
yeah you're not gonna get over on Nicki
Minaj she like she fits in she deserves
to be on the stage what Beyonce she
proved it and it's not about people
understand it's not about your music
it's about your adversity through life
the talent is one thing can you
it's the adversity that life's those
that you came to handle my music is
whatever you make it and I feel like
music is the future and just like it's
changing and people doing their own
interpretation of what they think is
music right and what we think is music
is like you know Patti LaBelle all the
great stuff but that's our era so is it
fair to interfere with your son that
could be 19 to say that ain't music
right would you what would you want your
parents telling you when we listen to
hip-hop the hibbity hip-hop
yeah that's not music right I just look
at it as wow I don't look at the music
like are we really getting oh right
that's all I'll be thinking like well we
really have seen some stuff so I just be
like how do i reinvent myself in the
future maybe futuristic Timbo that's how
I look at what goals do you feel like
you still besides you said changing the
sound like there's any specific goals
you slop and that's it man
night-night and show people that uh I
think I got a big thing when it come to
being a billionaire I want to provide
jobs for the community like I feel like
people what in the world do I possibly
with a billion dollars what could I
possibly go by in a lifetime I live
comfortably now so what is that gonna be
so different
yeah I'm trying to say so if I go to a
neighborhood in Africa and I could
provoke somebody killing somebody
because of money I'm gonna talk to him
and and give them the money I'm right
now what did you get from this now why
are you gonna shoot that dude concrete
hmm because what so what is your
difference now say I want to educate and
give at the same time if I take a
hundred million dollars and spread
throughout a community I'm like Martin
Luther King Hopper deuce Nana's like I
might as I own the road I do a lot on my
on my iPad now so how do it now I just
take ideas that I might get each day and
I go back and I take like about the end
of the month not gonna to take all my
ideas and then I start to produce
they're not bring in all my you know my
the team everybody and I said let me
hear what you got what you would she
will say on this or then I might say oh
that's dope and I just start piecing to
me now it's like IP stuff together mmm
like I like peace and great quality of
stuff because you get so much bundle of
great material you know from lyrics to
sounds so you gotta like for me it's
like I say blaze do your part okay we
should tweet that Tweety do your part
alright I'm gonna put now that they did
all their parts are tweaked they stuff
and moving around and then play it back
for them be like no I don't sound right
my voice don't sound like this or don't
so it's almost like a learning as I
build so it's like for me it's like
learning the new generation and being a
teacher for the new generation too but
also accepting and being a Saturday
cream oh yeah just let them turn like
okay hey man that's what y'all think
it's dope I mean I think it could be
this but guess what you only 23 you
don't I gotta wait till you get 28 like
we're futures now you know from you go
back to future music today to him to him
now it's a difference and it's gonna
evolve it's not gonna evolve how
J and Nas evolved but that's de world
that's how they evolve so we got to be
acceptable to what music is today and
not be so judgmental and people are they
saying and ain't talking abut they are
saying stuff to what they see every day
in life
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Jada Belle and
Kiki asked me to if there's something
you'd like me to cover in a future top
10 check out the link in the description
and go and cast your vote I'd also love
to know what did you learn from this
video what lesson really hit home the
hardest what are you going to
immediately apply somehow to your life
or to your business leave it down the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Kaylee and Bradley thank
you guys so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word taking that
picture posted online
I love the bird tattoo on the arm as
well I really hope you enjoyed the book
and you're able to apply it to your life
and your business and thank you again
for your support thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
I was looking at Expendables one day
uh-huh and I was like hum Sylvester
Stallone so you had the original crew
then you had the new crew and I'm like
who died got this new I got to create a
new crew but what happens is people be
afraid to go out once you know you make
success you make all my cells like
scripting myself down becoming back Tim
Mosley again Oh fine and talent and
rebuilding with my crew and just being
normal is that what you're doing right
now yeah Jimmy once said never you know
do stuff out of emotions and a lot of
things I've done was you know emotion
like you might write something about an
artist out of emotion and I'd like don't
do that right and you know because
because he did y'all and you know the
foundation you know like your [ __ ]
when we have a listening session and the
Village Voice because I asked stimulus
of questions about what he was working
with dreamy facts a question that's what
I'm saying and the thing is like you
gotta like go home vent to somebody and
it's really think about what are we
really here for write the crap of this
person now personally you might say I
didn't like he could have a bad day but
you know I've learned now that just
because stuff don't go right at that
moment I give people the benefit of the
doubt versus or the situation the
benefit of doubt because with that was
me now I do what if that was me before
when I was younger I never say what if
[Music]
and that just not cool to me no I'm
always the underdog I've been that way
you know even if I get the deuce of the
Year this year you know whatever they
got to give me got to speak because it's
a lot I want to say I'm gonna touch some
hearts at the Grammys I will be the talk
I will speak if I'm at that I'm
nominated and whatever I have to speak
it's not about winning I need to speak
to the world because when I talked to
the world I would touch the world and
that's all that matters to me it's
touching somebody
I will save somebody like if I get to
that podium
[Music]
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]